one two three
no no
[Music]
hello and welcome I'm Emma Fife your
guide and host as two worthy players
take on Diablo 4 but with a demonic
twist beside me we have a wheel of fuss
and debuffs inspired by the game every
two minutes we shall spin that wheel and
our players will take on whatever IRL
Boone or punishment the wheel should
decide let's meet them shall we hey I'm
Dave Klein I'm a producer at Gamespot
I'm Bailey Myers I'm a gaming content
producer at fandom I feel pretty good
about my chances with Diablo 4 what
about you Bailey um I'm feeling I'm
feeling all right about it I think I've
got enough practice in that I could
totally be smooth through some of these
dungeons yeah
reminder of the rules of the game you
will have 10 minutes to get as far as
you can in this dungeon working together
trying your best power of friendship
will hopefully see you through however
in theory a buff should affect you
positively and and vice versa for a
debuff but who knows only time will tell
are you you ready this sounds like a
horrible thing I'm very scared cool
great okay here we go five four three
three
artillery Shrine first
I hope this is a dungeon me too
oh my
God
oh my gosh oh this is nothing with our
buff wow Dave you got a real in-game
buff oh yeah okay I I just hear a race
and I go race time race time we're not
racing against each other
yeah but we have to be about two minutes
so we don't get some like weird debuff
thing oh yes
maybe yes yes as a matter of fact it is
a yes because your first spin of the
wheel has landed on a buff so
congratulations oh Ben will you please
bring our Intrepid players their
Vitality Elixir
all right so there you go these are
mysterious looking cheers have a nice
sip
[Applause]
it's all right it's very uh energy I
know exactly what it is
another gold thing an event's gonna
happen whoa how are those
working out Brio I feel like I'm moving
faster yeah
surprised I feel so focused
life
full of vigor full of life and vigor we
definitely had a nice potion for sure
okay
it's time to spin the wheel
s my last time was fine though right it
was okay it's all good we got a buff
last time
you did it this time you got a debuff
you are now confused and what that means
for you IRL is while you're still able
to play you now have to play with your
controllers upside down this could be
really interesting okay yeah good right
Dave good job okay yep that's good you
know like those games where all of a
sudden it blips the controller it's like
Up Is Down I don't like that yeah it
always throws me off and this is like
that on 10 times 10. oh
okay how's it going for you over there
difficult I just threw daggers at a wall
for like a full 20 seconds I know I saw
it considering that I can just kind of
walk and hold X uh-huh as a barbarian
bro so I'm not using any of my like
specialist extra skills because I don't
know which buttons which Bailey it seems
like you found a nice spot to just stand
and hold a button yeah I'm facing the
right direction you know it works it's
okay it's okay wait oh let's go let's go
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry why would
your mother leave you like that oh I
wasn't talking to you that's that was
the game that wasn't me why Why didn't
it was that was the game you were
looking directly
no all right well it's about to maybe
get even more perfect we're certainly
more interesting no because it's been
two minutes so that means we're gonna
spin the wheels wait do we have to do
this like the whole time or is the buff
cancel out the buff cancels out of
previous buff okay we got a really good
one coming your way this is Diablos
Inferno
[Applause]
but it has the word Inferno in it yes
Inferno does imply hot so what I have
here right now are some chicken tenders
for you oh that's that is pungent uh in
my nostrils here you go which one's mine
uh Bailey yours is the one that's uh
green and yellow great
thank you thank you for that this is a
lot
all right well cheers no we're not
touching them
okay I can't believe how much you put on
this
oh no we have to we have to just be
brave one two three
no
oh are you gonna jump off a bridge
there's there's nowhere to go I love to
jump off a bridge right now everything's
good yeah go down they go down the
ladder ladder go down
bro I hate this oh I hate this
[Music]
living here
the thing that's real fun about this
debuff is even though two minutes will
end this gonna still be with you
I need a tissue yeah
okay oh Jesus so we've landed on another
debuff this one's not so bad why it's
dazed I'm already dazed okay well you're
about to be even more dazed Ben please
bring our players their new hands
honestly in comparison so you're not
gonna be playing with those bare hands
on and also you're gonna need to put on
those really cool glasses
if we have to do a boss fight like this
we are gonna die
that's good
where are we oh
as far as I can tell we're uh between
several rows of green plastic
if we have to fight a boss right now I
swear to God we are gonna die
oh boy oh geez we're cool squad I feel
so cool right now cool squad never felt
cooler cool Dave and cool Bailey oh no
being cool
okay okay all right I'm gonna stop on
them it's gonna be real cool oh hell
yeah
you can make yourselves a little less
cool that's cool and take off
this I'd love to we're at another two
minute Mark which means it's time to
spin the wheel okay for our very last
buff or debuff I feel like I can't hear
on my left ear anymore
we have great news for you because it's
above yay it's The Barbarians Warcraft
I still feel like I'm being debuffed
right now by the way well
that's an opinion all right so the
barbarians war cry means that I am now
going to shout inspirational quotes at
you for the next two minutes
here we go okay
[Music]
we do not see what has been done we only
see what remains to be done is that
supposed to be inspiring is that
inspiring it's very inspiring what is we
only see what remains to be done that's
like the opposite of inspiring no it
means that there's been a lot of people
who've accomplished things before you
and all you have to do is focus on the
task ahead who wrote that Ariana Grande
no Diablo 2. oh
a life unlived is no different than
death
yeah I I does that mean when we die it's
going to be like a life this is not
don't run away from me I don't know
about this inspiration Hey listen we're
working with the material we have these
are all called from Diablo games
hurry now the sands of time slow for no
one okay that's I guess okay
you know we were gonna stop them in 10
minutes but they tried so hard and were
such good sports that we thought it'd be
real nice to let them keep playing until
they got to the boss
oh wait we found a pool of Health we
might be a boss
oh God I think this is the boss
we have to like okay we have to kill her
hell spawn first right oh there's two
Health one there's one for each of you
yeah it's cute that's great
maybe this one will be more
inspirational for a barbarian please
give it to me to a man who only knows
iron there is no greater magic than
steel yes I I feel that I believe in
that
now I'm inspired to kill this hell spawn
did we get her we killed her
[Applause]
relations you have passed our Diablo for
Buffs and debuffs challenge as much as
anybody could really pass it uh Bailey
what would you say was your favorite
part of today I think my favorite part
of today was eating the chicken tender
I'm just kidding of course it wasn't
that Dave how's your mouth doing which
camera am I supposed to look at you look
at me
um
it's not good why don't you put so much
on what's wrong with you
it's not fun today that was not fun you
know my hand actually kind of hurts from
where it kind of touched it when I was
oh that must be really hard for you it
is I was so inspired when the cool squad
truly got together yeah we we kicked
major demon butt I think and I imagine
next time we play Diablo it'll be a
little bit easier
I don't even care
thanks to Blizzard and the Diablo team
for this hellish experience we can't
wait to experience everything Sanctuary
has to offer pre-purchase Diablo 4
Ultimate Edition for in-game exclusives
and crossover goodies meet your maker
when Diablo 4 Launches on June 6th
foreign